hey we love guys my name is a Chenoweth
episode 41 of game programming so this
time we're going to take a look at a
very simple episode just taking a look
at what the player class is what it does
and how it works so we've sort of
created this like this framework of um
this hierarchy really of have all these
subclasses and they all sort of get back
from entity right entities like the the
route the mother of all forgetting
things and T's a yes but yeah so the
entity is like it's like the head right
it's a top and then we sort of go down
to mob and then from more but we branch
off to you know mobs so in other words a
mob I said last time was basically a
character or a you know like a character
yeah so could be the player it could be
other players
it could be animals anything basically
anything that moves them is that
something that's mobile so if we
actually on over here now navigator are
right on the mob fold if we right-click
hit new in class we can actually create
a new player class we're gonna call this
player and it would probably just be in
the mob we could probably put it its own
package but I'm just thinking right now
I don't think I will know just because
I'm just because you know there's
probably not going to be any subclass to
player there's not gonna be any anything
related to player that's going to be in
the player folder so if there's nothing
in them might as well just credit in the
mob folder so we'll just hit finish and
here we go so public class the player
first thing we need to do is make sure
that it extends mob and because in the
same class we won't even have to import
that and we need a few things here but
I'm just thinking I might save it for
another episode so that way sort of you
know so that I sort of cover each
episode by a subject not multiple
subjects so what I will do though is
probably one of his constructor first of
all there is going to be a constructor
with X&Y there's probably going to be a
another constructor with nothing
and that's going to constructors now X&Y
why is there a constructor with X&Y um
the reason is sometimes players need to
be created at a specific location so
public player might just create a player
at at a default location like a spawning
location but sometimes you know for
whatever reason there is an I'm thinking
of right now is like in realm of the mad
God when you actually enter a different
realm you actually you know you appear
at a specific like spawn point right and
what happens is you know I obviously I
don't know the actual code to realm of
the mad God but I would imagine what
happens is your as you play a unit it de
spawns from the previous realm it loads
the new realm into the game and then it
finally it creates a new player object
for you at a particular location because
obviously you basically know that every
time you spawn you sorta spawn at a
different location so as a career set
your location in this credit at x and y
so if we go back to our entity thing
that is really the place that has x and
y so in other words we obviously don't
need to create int X in NY we don't
actually need to create those variables
in the player class we can simply just
say that this dot x equals x and they're
still y equals y and that's it because
this dot X we actually control click on
that on that it'll take us back to the
entity class so you can see where the
variable is actually defined so that's
brilliant the other thing is for this
thing we'll talk about that in another
episode because again I don't want to
you know deal with half-ass objection
one video and then you know come back to
the same subject in another video I sort
of want to cover one subject matter in
one in one video so that I'm not you
know sort of confusing people being like
alright well we're going to be covering
inputs today but um to do that you
should watch the previous episode
because I still did half of it then no I
won't do it all in one video ok so the
other things we need is the update
method so when it whenever we actually
hit woops public void update when
whenever we sort of hit um I don't know
an arrow key but I'm basically basically
when we move when we hit something on
our keyboard we want to play to move so
yeah we're not
their method and finally a render method
so yeah and the render method of course
will render again now few things you can
see here that update actually overrides
another update um it just put a
breakpoint there it actually overrides
if we go to here if we arm if we
actually control click on this override
thing it'll actually take us to it till
it's true so update and of course update
then overrides the update in our entity
think that's wonderful right what that
tells me right away is that we don't
actually need to call player to update
to update the player however render
doesn't override anything and primary
reason is we don't actually have random
method in our mob class now whether we
will or won't I'm not a hundred percent
sure if actually want to have a random
method in the mob class let me just
think quickly well all mobs need to
round up so to be honest I probably will
pop to put it here and I'll make it
public obviously Brendan method needs to
be public so does update just because we
will be accessing them in other in other
classes so if we go back here you'll see
the green arrow has appeared meaning
that we are actually overriding it from
mob
that's brilliant alright so that is the
basic structure for our player class
next time we'll probably cover input so
in other words you can see that if we go
back to our game class the way that the
our player moves you know sort of works
over here so this flows the map and it's
sort of in the game that Java update
method it's not actually moving the
player it's sort of just scrolling the
screen and you know obviously when I'm
actually keeping track of where the
player is we're just you know keeping
dragging for x and y variables will move
all that into our player class and we
will actually probably you know finish
up input for the player object so that
any of any players in our game can
actually move you know using the arrow
keys for their individual instances but
yeah anyway guys I hope you enjoyed this
episode of game programming if you did
please hit that like button and I will
see you guys next time goodbye